hey here's something a little different
in the context of the Trump Russia
investigation and the indictments that
we've been seeing and talk of
impeachment resignation maybe someday
criminal charges against Donald Trump
there's a question that's come up now a
handful of times from people in the
email and in comments online which is
what about an insanity defense is it
possible that Donald Trump if he were at
some point to be indicted or charged for
who knows what and we're thinking ahead
quite a bit here could he maybe get away
with an insanity defense and why would
people even be asking about that right
maybe part of it is that we've talked
about Donald Trump showing some signs
maybe early signs of dementia or
Alzheimer's which of course aren't
mental illness they're disorders of the
brain but certainly they affect mental
health and sort of whether you are
cognitively able to carry out a job but
let's think through it a little bit
because I think it's an interesting
question the first thing to know and to
be aware of is that at the top level
insanity defense is number one are
really rare and number two even when
used they tend not to work okay
similarly to how we hear a lot about
terrorist attacks and people think that
they're more likely than in reality we
hear stories about insanity defenses but
the truth is that at least according to
one study I looked at number one under
1% of all cases even attempt an insanity
defense and when it's used it works
meaning you know it leads to avert
verdict of not guilty by reason of
insanity only about one out of four
times right roughly 25 percent of the
time when the insanity defense does work
meaning under one percent of cases
attempted of those only 25 percent
successfully use it 90 percent of that
25 percent of that 1% okay so we're
talking about you know small number here
90% of that time the individual who
successfully uses the defense had been
diagnosed formally with a mental illness
before the alleged acts that they have
been accused for and the trial in
question right and part of this has to
do with burden of
interesting that this has to do with an
assassination attempt against the
president but after Ronald Reagan's
attempted assassin was found not guilty
by reason of insanity the burden of
proof in an insanity defense shifted to
the defense that's very significant
normally in the American justice system
the prosecution has to prove their case
before a judge or jury beyond a
reasonable doubt and the defense merely
needs to create or point out reasonable
doubt in order to as the law is written
obtain an acquittal and not guilty
verdict when you put forward an insanity
defense it is the defense attorneys who
have to prove with clear and convincing
evidence that the person they are
defending that the defendant is insane
and that that insanity exculpate s--
them having committed the crime legally
speaking and that is really really tough
the other aspect for this which is which
is difficult with Trump we're not
difficult but doesn't really align with
what we know about him is that part of
the basis for being legally insane
relates to being unable to distinguish
right from wrong I don't believe that
Donald Trump is unable to distinguish
right from wrong I think Trump knows
right from wrong but his delusional
megalomaniac personality makes him think
that he's untouchable right that he can
get away with these things that he
probably to some extent realizes aren't
okay things to be doing and that is sort
of the opposite of an insanity defense
that that is actually something that
would be considered an aggravating
factor sort of a total disregard for the
rightness or wrongness of action so
really for a possible successful
insanity defense for Trump and again
this is if at some point it came up and
we have no idea that it ever will it
would probably be only if we had some
kind of actual diagnosis that would
prove Trump had diminished capacity for
understanding the real world which for
Trump really would be dementia or
Alzheimer's long story short I think we
shouldn't be counting on it and quite
frankly I think we shouldn't even really
be thinking about it let's let the
investigations happen as
they should as as Robert Moeller is
carrying them out and then we'll deal
with the consequences if and when we we
know them and in the meantime let's try
to keep winning some elections like
Democrats were able to do on Tuesday
this week